well let's start this morning with
another very difficult round of sunday
headlines for the government focused on
sexual misconduct and the judgment of
the prime minister we're now joined by
the work and pension secretary therese
coffey thank you very much for being uh
with us good morning
i don't need to remind you of course you
know chris pincher's resigned had the
whip suspended over these allegations uh
that he groped two men at the carlton
club on wednesday night
in today's newspapers there are multiple
other allegations about his behavior
stretching back years
were you aware
of these concerns around the behavior of
mr pincher before this week
i think first of all it's important to
set out that of course serious
allegations were made they were dealt
with decisively not only did uh uh
the previous day that chris had already
resigned as deputy chief whip uh but
when people came forward and made those
formal complaints uh appropriately
they're now going to be investigating it
was right then for the chief whip uh
with the agreement of the prime minister
to suspend the whip but um you know i've
been in parliament the same length of
time as chris pincher i don't pretend to
be part of the general chatter rumor
mill uh discussions i know chris hasn't
been i don't believe he's been a
long-term relationship but that's about
as far as my knowledge goes
so just to be crystal clear
before this week were you aware of any
allegations or concerns over the
behavior of chris pincher
no i wasn't as a just not part of that
sort of
uh kind of chatter group as it were um
and i mean to be fair to be fair it's
not a chatter group is it this guy the
last time he was in the whips office he
had to resign he actually referred
himself to the police after some
accusations it's not just westminster
chatter there were serious concerns
about the behaviour of this man
well sophie as you say he pointed out um
i think an allegation was made from
prior to when
chris pincher been an mp
and there was an investigation uh that
was uh chris was cleared at the time and
he rejoined the government at that time
so obviously that was in the public
domain but um
as i say these allegations have been
made and it's really important that when
uh such behavior it's when people are
concerned about this instead of just
different elements that they come
forward and make those complaints you
know to the police if necessary
and i'm pleased that the this
investigation is now underway it's been
dealt with uh seriously uh and meanwhile
the government will continue to get on
with delivering uh priorities as it's
trying to do in a variety of ways okay
um you say you weren't aware of any uh
allegations around him i just want to
talk about what the prime minister knew
and when um because boris johnson of
course made christman to the deputy whip
in february
when he was given that job was the prime
minister aware of any allegations about
his behavior
well i don't know about any individual
conversations um it's
been suggested that uh there was a
discussion a referral to pet uh which is
happens with all ministerial
appointments actually that uh there's an
element of a bit of vetting that goes on
uh but ultimately the decision is that
of the prime minister uh i'm clear that
uh i'd say i'm not part of those
individual conversations um
chris had served in government before
and uh was uh had been a minister
elsewhere so i'm not aware that there
was anything that was brought to the
attention of the prime minister uh to
make that change
sorry i i'm still not really clear um
you say you weren't aware of any reports
uh you say that everyone is passed on
for vetting if they you know become
uh are given a position
was the prime minister aware of
allegations around chris prince's
behavior when he was made deputy chief
whip in february
well i've just said to you i'm not
involved in any of those uh direct
conversations well why don't why don't
you ask but i just i don't you know i i
get you know perhaps it's easier just to
be able to come on these programs and
say look i don't know so who knows but
but surely you must ask to try and find
out you know that's the first thing that
most people would do when did the prime
minister know so that when i am asked
this question i can give the answer
well as i've just outlined to you what
um has been suggested in terms of uh
things were referred uh but nevertheless
uh when somebody phoned the prime
minister uh particularly on friday i
think it was um he agreed with the chief
whip that these whip should uh the whip
should be suspended
i genuinely don't understand that
sentence that um it was suggested and
things were referred i don't what does
that mean
well i think it's been well laid out um
sophie that uh
when the appointment for becoming deputy
chief whip again um moving from a
different ministerial post uh it was uh
that went through vetting process like
normal um but as i say i'm not directly
involved in those discussions i'm not
going to try and do so and i'm not part
of that more general uh kind of rumor
speculation meal within westminster but
nevertheless sorry i'm just going to
come in again i'm just going to come in
again apologies and you don't apologize
i'm just going to give you the same
answer sophie but i don't i don't
understand the answer
forgive me you say it was well laid out
that he went through a vetting process
like normal but the question is were was
the prime minister aware of allegations
about his behavior
i'm not aware that he was made aware of
like specific claims about uh any
particular incidents or anything like
that no i'm not i don't believe he was
aware that's what i've been told today
um but uh that's uh
uh you were asking more about more
general rumors and i have no idea what
conversations have been had i'm just no
i am aware that he the prime minister
was not aware of specific claims that
had been made and as to say when
ultimately he resigned uh chris resigned
the whip
sorry resigned as deputy chief whip and
then when specific things were brought
directly to the attention of the prime
minister they agreed with the chief whip
to suspend the whip okay so you say that
as far as you know the prime minister
was not made aware of specific claims in
2017 so i feel that's quite important if
you just look at what's in the papers
today sunday mirror the front page the
prime minister was warned twice of
concerns on the deputy chief whip male
on sunday the prime minister knew all
about
groping tory two years ago the sunday
telegraph the pm turned a blind eye to
the sex past warnings they say that
craig whittaker actually resigned from
the whips office because of the prime
minister's decision to appoint chris
pincher we know of course uh dominick
cummings tweeted this week to say if the
pm didn't know about pinscher as he's
claiming why did he repeatedly refer to
him laughingly in number 10 as pincher
by name pinscher by nature long before
appointing him do you really believe the
prime minister was not aware of any
specific allegations
um i've just suggested all said i don't
think the pm was aware of specific
claims no it was news to me in the morn
this morning to read the reason given
why craig whittaker resigned from
government
and i have no idea what dominic cummings
tweets on anything so i don't follow his
twitter handle
okay
okay um there's been a bit of a shifting
position from number 10 uh which we're
trying to kind of grapple with um
initially we said the prime minister
didn't know now number 10 seemed to be
saying that some allegations were raised
at the time that he got the job in
february's reshuffle but
the quotas in the absence of any formal
complaint it was not appropriate to stop
the appointment on the basis of
unsubstantiated
allegations
do you believe that's the correct
position that it was the right thing
just to give him the job even despite
the fact that there were these
unsubstantiated allegations
i think the prime minister made the
choice he thought was best of it for the
interests of
the parliamentary party um we've been
through interesting and sorry the
government in order to help get
government business through
chris had been a minister for some time
in different departments and uh went
back into the whips office
as i say the uh there's a number of um
activities we are trying to get on with
uh in in terms of government and getting
legislation through the house
as so we can get on and deliver people's
priorities and that's the sort of thing
that we're doing uh right now we've just
passed a uh an act of parliament in
order to make sure we can make cost of
living payments to those people so it's
it's there are a variety of ways of or
reasons why somebody will be asked to
fulfill a particular role i just want to
ask you
personally you know because we know
obviously that victims of
sexual misconduct of sexual assault can
be very reluctant to make formal
complaints particularly if there's a
power imbalance obviously
given that there were these
unsubstantiated allegations do you think
that it was right for chris pincher to
be appointed to that important job in
february
well what i think is right is that
people should have the confidence come
forward whether they want to do that
through the um icgs which has been set
out it's not what i asked to take
obviously
it's not the question that i asked
well i'm explaining that i think it's
important that people should have the
confidence to follow the procedures that
have been put in place deliberately
because of uh situations like this
i'm very wish people would go to the
police more with allegations uh if they
feel uh that the crime has been
committed but importantly i think that
uh
as i said earlier i'm not prone to privy
to the exact conversations that went on
i have been told that pm was not made
aware of specific claims uh and indeed
there's an aspect of the vetting process
that every ministerial appointment goes
through but ultimately it's positioned
the prime minister and i believe he made
that in good faith
you know
i can't help but thinking that a lot of
people listen to this
will be feeling frankly that you're
dancing on the head of the pin by saying
specific allegations
that he was aware of general concerns
but because you're going to say specific
allegations do you think you can just
wriggle out of it
it's not a case of that i've said at the
very beginning sophie i'm not priority
to conversations that the prime minister
has it on on this topic or indeed many
other topics uh all i know is uh that uh
once serious allegations have been made
uh the effective action has been taken
is the real problem here
that the fact is that the standards of
this government are set by the prime
minister how can he rigidly enforce them
if he himself has broken the law in
office we know of course that he's been
investigated on everything from how he
refurbished his flat to whether or not
he lied to parliament or misled
parliament to top that off his ethics
chief has just
just resigned he's not even going to
bother replacing him is the real issue
the fact that the standards of this
government are set from the top
well what i see from the prime minister
is the leadership that he's showing one
tackling issues in this country uh
whether that's the priority of uh trying
to level up across the country i also
see his leadership in the world he's
just spent the week uh particularly uh
with commonwealth but also with uh the
g7 and nate so this kind of thing
doesn't matter then is that what you're
saying because i'm saying what you're
doing leading you know standards don't
matter what i'm saying is the leadership
qualities of the prime minister are very
evident i think on other matters uh of
course uh the it's the privileged
committee that will be uh considering uh
the investigation about whether the
prime minister knowingly misled
parliament uh and indeed for this
situation involving chris pincher that
now needs to go through its formal
process uh so it's uh important that
those issues and those processes are
followed and indeed i'm not quite sure
how the committee gets underway but they
will be soon
um i want to talk a bit about the wider
culture in westminster now in the last
year this has happened five times chris
pincher imran khan bob roberts david
warburton neil parish all conservative
mps who have resigned or have been
suspended for allegations of sexual
misconduct i mean there are 271 male
conservative mps in the last year alone
five of them have been suspended that is
an incredible ratio is there a specific
problem with conservative men
i don't think that's the case at all
sophie
i don't know the situation the scenarios
elsewhere
um one mp uh well no longer an mp imran
khan has been convicted of an
something that happened before he became
a member of parliament
and other investigations are underway so
i'm not going to comment on individual
investigations because it's
process needs to be followed understand
that and i'm not asking you to do that
um
let's let's you know because it does
feel
frankly that you know we're sitting in
studios in every
regular regularly we're talking about
the culture and westminster we're
talking about these kind of misconduct
allegations and what i'm interested in
now is what do you think should
happen there are six bars in the commons
and the lords there are 30 in the
parliamentary estate is it time to
seriously talk about closing
parliament's bars
well i think in terms of parliament's
bars we have a particular sort of
working hours we have particular and a
lot of these situations that you're
referring to i don't think happened in
the bars so
that's a
a matter i guess for discussion within
parliament but we've already reduced the
number of um drinking and eating outlets
uh within parliament
but importantly what does matter in
terms of culture is actually being a
government and a parliament that gets on
and deliver
the priorities of the people okay that's
what i would continue to do and that's
what i see it sounds like a majority of
people it sounds like you're not uh
seriously looking at closing
parliament's bars and how about reform
of working practices a speaker's talked
for example about mps no longer directly
employing staff so it's easier for them
to make hr complaints andrew lessons
talked about maybe having a proper hr
system for parliament is that something
that can change
well an hr system for parliament has
been introduced so i'm not quite sure
what the background to that is it's
always been the case that mps had
parliamentary support in terms of the
fact that they are employers uh but
there is a separate process now where
people can get advice and but do you
think anything should change around the
staff along to a trade union as well do
you think anything else should change
around working you know the working
structure in parliament
well i think that we have a parliament
uh in westminster we sit for more hours
than anywhere else in the world we have
two chambers of the debate so this is
very busy with the select committees
with all sorts of other activities that
go on so there is a certainly um a huge
amount of time
spent understandably uh so no change
debating important issues
no specific changes then you don't think
i'm not aware of specific changes i
think it's important that mps continue
to employ the people who work for them
uh i think that relationship is really
is okay absolutely critical uh but
nevertheless uh as i say over the past
few years new processes have been
introduced in terms of that but
meanwhile most of the staff most of the
mps are just getting on doing their
absolute job of representing
constituents or indeed scrutinizing
legislation and that's to say why we are
working on things like the cost of
living challenge uh also elements you
know trying to help people in their
daily lives this summer a lot of people
perhaps not so confident of the weather
of the british uh of britain are trying
to get abroad and again we're taking
with us
in a minute reducing that
i will talk to you about that in a
minute but it just it just sounds like
you know there's no change that you
think is necessary even though the
sunday times is reporting 56 mps
apparently being investigated for sexual
misconduct five conservative mps had to
resign in the last year alone no change
i just want to ask you
you know a personal question because
because i get that it's it's a difficult
position that you're in this morning i i
understand that
um
you know how's it been um
to be you know like a woman in the
conservative party listening
over the last couple of years to some of
these allegations that have been made
victims speaking out often anonymously
because they feel that they can't do so
on the record
the reputation of parliament is
is so low and it does really feel
doesn't it as if
there's so many concerns about the
behavior of mps how does it feel for you
i think there are more women mps in
parliament than ever before
and i can assure you if people approach
me i would do my best although
uh daryl said uh going to the icgs is
the best way for people to uh lodges
lodge complaints in order to tackle that
you know
we have to be professional
there are different situations that
happen where people have been
unprofessional and unpleasant and that
needs to be tackled absolutely i'm very
much in favor of firm
dealing with these things firmly uh
we need to continue to try and encourage
people to come forward and as i say go
to the police uh if they believe that a
crime has been committed nobody in that
regard should be feeling that they've
got some protection they haven't we need
to continue to try and make sure we have
the highest standards behavior
especially in the palace of westminster
okay there you go um
well we do need to move on to talk about
some other subjects now and there's
chaos at the airports you mentioned it
earlier holidays being ruined thanks to
cancelled flights uh the fact that there
is this staffing crisis um the
government's fast tracking security
checks for new airport bag handlers to
try and improve things what's the idea
and are there any security concerns
around this
well certainly uh airports um and uh
other
airlines released a lot of people um
after the fellow schemer come to an end
perhaps not anticipating the desire for
people to get out of the country uh
that's why we've been running job fairs
in places like gatwick airport in order
to get people into that work i think
it's really um the government has
responded we've reduced the amount of
time in order to do various checks i
think counterterrorism is now down to 10
days so we've prioritized that
recognizing the pressures on airlines
this summer but also um i know grant
sheps the transport secretary had
already made some changes so people
could start training in less secure
parts of the airport rather than waiting
for the full checks so together we have
been putting forward our approach in
order to help the airlines but what it's
really matters that when airlines offer
flights that they have confidence these
can be delivered
and indeed making sure that their
passengers know well in advance
whether or not their flight's going to
be honoured not making cancellations at
the last minute
of course i'm very keen for people to
stay in this country and spend a lot of
money in the uk
but i understand that it's important
that they have a system that they have
confidence in and rightly they'll get
compensation if flights are suddenly
cancelled okay um we're in a slightly
strange position aren't we where it's
almost like the jobs market is a bit too
hot you have very low unemployment
levels but a record level of vacancies
1.3 million now the business minister
paul scully at telstra news recently
that effectively people who want to
should work longer hours to try and ease
this he said there are a record number
of vacancies there are also people who
have recalibrated what they want to do
when they're on furlough we want to make
sure that those people that are not
necessarily working full-time through
universal credit we can get them back
into work to be more productive
do you agree with him that perhaps
people recalibrated what they wanted to
do during the pandemic and actually it
may be a good time to try and boost
their hours
well i think that's a fair um
kind of top level analysis certainly
when people were put on furlough others
they started looking for other types of
jobs
they resort a different work-life
balance i think there is something here
about employers thinking about the
flexibility they can offer about whether
everything has to be a 12-shift starting
at 4am or whatever it is
so to try and make that more attractive
to people to come and do that job again
certainly in terms of people on benefits
and out of work in the last five months
we've got over half a million people
into work through our way to work
campaign that's a real achievement we've
had some record highs of getting people
to work in the last few months and we
will continue to do that but it's
important that we try and get people to
progress in work as well
but we'll keep trying to match those
vacancies and as i say we're at the
moment we're having a job monthly jobs
fair in gatwick airport to try and
bridge that gap okay and then just very
finally uh because we are almost out of
time and boris johnson's election pledge
to build 40 new hospitals by 2030 is now
facing a review by the government
spending watchdogs they're looking into
value for money review whether the
hospitals will in fact be new it was
such a big part of the election campaign
wasn't i remember that pledge really
well that's not a great look is it
well off top my head i'm trying to
remember the numbers i think we've
already done six i think there are five
in progress um and underway and this is
a reasonably long-term project the nao
is the is actually parliament's um uh an
organization of parliament and it's up
to them to uh work with the public
accounts committee to decide what
elements they want to investigate in
terms of the use of taxpayers money so
it's uh we are getting on with that job
and i know many communities around the
country are really appreciating the
additional facilities the rebuilt
facilities as well as the brand new
facilities
in order to make sure that they have
21st century healthcare available to uh
treat them as patients
okay thank you very much for being on
the program this morning to reuse coffee
there
for the government